I want to start with congratulations
I've seen the whole season I would be
stunned if you guys don't get a season
two uh it turned out great thank you
thank you thank you
so I have to start with the most
important question
um how much fun is it watching Kurt wood
uh calling someone a dumbass or being
part of a scene where he's calling
someone a dumbass oh my gosh this is
amazing highlight of my life I mean I
think we all watched the show and being
able to experience it in real life was
very surreal
um but definitely yeah the Highlight
like you said and it's such a funny
sorry it's such a funny contrast because
kurtwood is just like the nicest human
being I know and then I get in a scene
with him and I'm terrified because I'm
like is he gonna call me a dumbass I'm
so scared he's never called me a dumbass
though you're smart
yeah no definitely a bucket list thing
oh yeah
for all of you guys once you got past
did you feel the need to like binge All
of That 70s Show to feel like you needed
to see the whole thing I watched the
whole thing before and like I know that
I watched it three times all the way
through before because before we even
got like I even knew about that 90 show
but like definitely definitely had to
re-watch everything just to relive that
you haven't seen it yet for me
no for me I mean I hadn't seen it when I
first got the audition so I like found
clips on YouTube and stuff but then I
ended up actually buying the box set and
just been doing the whole same yeah I
hadn't seen it either and then once I
got the audition for it I was like okay
I need to watch an episode just to suss
it out and then I loved it like even if
I didn't get the role I would have
watched the whole thing anyway and now
I've seen the whole thing and yeah I
mean can I be a fan like does like yeah
of course we're huge fans I I love
learning about the behind the scenes the
making of a show
um so for each of you guys
um what do you think would surprise soon
to be fans of the show in terms of like
the making of it
I think because we filmed during covid
times I think that the fact that we had
a live studio audience was really cool
it was I think all of our first six I
don't know it was my first time
audience so it was really you know
without them it wouldn't have been the
same because we just vibe off of them
and their energy and their laughter so
yeah I literally cried the first live
audience show I'm so happy and I was
freaking out because I thought my makeup
was going to get rid of Eli it put so
much effort into it
yeah the eyeliner the go on eyeliner
yeah I've spoken to a lot of casts and
they all a lot of a lot of times they
all have a group chat you know in
WhatsApp or whatever and I'm assuming
maybe you guys do as well and I'm
curious which of you is the one who
texts way too much oh my gosh you know
sometimes I text into the abyss like
multiple texts at a time and it's like
crickets yeah for two weeks and then
someone responds and then like is reborn
again but sometimes I'm just like hey
guys look I I found these pictures of us
nothing for two weeks so sometimes
[Laughter]
no we're getting responding we're gonna
meet each other every day I feel like no
like afterwards Sam and Max are really
good at messaging in the group chat
they're like they message the most for
sure I'm a terrible messenger in general
yeah
I feel like you're good at responding
too yeah I try to yeah I'm really bad
that's awful texture in general I have
like 500 unread texts nothing no random
Wren text like he's 60 years old
it works that that was great uh
season is I believe 10 episodes for each
of you which is your favorite episode
and why
I I oh that's hard to think I love
um episode eight because I mean they're
all great but that one was just so much
fun to film I think it was actually the
last one that we filmed yeah and also
you know sibling storyline keep an eye
out I was actually going to say the same
one I love that episode yeah no me too
because I feel like for me my favorite
episode to actually film was probably
episode six just because that has like a
ton of interesting stuff in it
um but yeah I mean watching looking back
my favorite episode to watch is like
episode eight because it has a a lot of
really sweet moments because it was our
last week filming and like the circle
scene in that episode was like the last
scene that we filmed so it's like it's
bittersweet watching it back definitely
mine was probably episode five because
well I was called a sex boy
[Laughter]
um
um but no that episode I had a lot of
things in front of the audience and it
was really fun and no it was it was a
special episode for Ozzy
I don't necessarily have a favorite
episode I think just kind of when we got
the hang of and a really good feel of
the show and our characters
starting from episode two when we're all
really comfortable with each other and
onset all the episodes we shot from that
on they're very fun the whole experience
awesome yeah we all get along really
well which is really lucky
so I am curious because uh I I'm I'm
confident this is going to get a season
two and I'm curious because the the
thing about the show is that you are
going it's the summer time so have you
asked like the creators if we get a
season two is it just gonna jump ahead
you know another year to the next summer
have you like I'm just curious about
that I I think so I think their plan was
to do it every season in the summer yeah
um I think they I think they said that I
think that's that's what I've heard yeah
from uh from the Turners yeah yeah
yeah I heard that as well
on that note I gotta stop I'm just gonna
say congrats good luck with the rest of
your speed dating and I hope this show
is a huge thank you